et maintenant voici chouchou
[Applaudissements]
merci ou dallas quelle entrée je suis
chaud mais alors là c'est ça c'est
l'entrée qu'on me le mettre en sortir et
ça fait plaisir
alors je joue je te regarde jamais la
télé pareil bonsoir les gens comment je
parle comme un juge après grave ça va
j'adresse à découvrir et g oui on
ouverture totale
il connaît pas bien la télévision jeu sa
première télévision en tous les cas je
vais tout vous est l'héroïne d'un film
de merzak allouache intitulé she
ressortent à renwez mars à sa fille mal
à la gorge
c'est un petit peu qui sort le 19 mars
comment ça va à sochaux
bon ça va bien là je dois dire sa
première fois de ma vie je mets les
pieds dans un plateau à moussan me
sentais bien là sur ce plateau ça va ça
va mal et je me sens bien je suis
content comme si j'étais une vedette
alors que 13 ou par m
je comprends pas
je pense que je parle mais je donne le
droit c
ces lattes et c'est comme cela télévie
c'est la télévision d'accord ça va alors
dites moi je joue sérieusement c'est
votre vrai prénom chouchou où ça vient
des cacahuètes ou des noeuds pour les
cheveux noirs comme m non c'est un
pseudonyme
c'est à dire quand même on rigole on
rigole mais ça va il ya des moments
peut-être je vais pas rigoler je suis
gentil mais j'ai pas monsieur young and
that way
non
il va
je dois dire bon à vous même et à toute
la france parce qu'ils croient à la
france elle regarde c'est la france
regarde je suis ce soit en même temps je
suis un pseudonyme c'est pas mon vrai
nom c'est à dire bah mon vrai nom c'est
choukri et comme j'étais je vais pas
raconter toute ma vie là mais quand même
on m'appelait chouchou parce qu'ils
étaient quelque chose d'affectueux est
facile que fouquet vous connaissez gad
elmaleh le promoteur du film ben si je
le connaissais elle allait cependant
bien avant à wimille et il est plutôt
sympathique non les sympathiques bon je
peux pas te raconter mais ben may mais
vous l'avez connu comme enjeu si ce
n'est pas indiscret merci ça fait
plaisir
alors là je parle on me donnait la
limonade
c'est l'un de radeaux gad elmaleh je les
connais à la place clichy
ah ouais parce que je travaille dans un
cabaret un moment donné je savais qu'il
faisait quand même la malice
parce que j'étais quelqu'un tu sais tu
connais d'artistes à fouiner à gauche
affolé à droite attention un jour tu te
retrouves de l'ulb et il fallait il
aller à l'apocalypse garder le même où
elle allait la pokal est un bon oui oui
et il est plutôt beau mec non quand même
des bonnes femmes beau gosse est en
baisse mais il a des yeux et la 18 du
biche qu'on ait vu je le fais sans
fantasme
gilles porte et c'est pourquoi j'ai peur
lardy sottise et pourquoi pas ce qui lui
est demandé pour la reva directives et
puis on est beaucoup regardé au maghreb
en algérie en tunisie au maroc c'est
bien d'ailleurs je salue la maghrebi
toute entière mais aussi d'ailleurs moi
aussi je joue
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous faisiez
avant de faire du cinéma avant de faire
des cinémas ouais je travaille et qu'on
a assistante d'une psychanalyste
je travaille aussi comme serveuse à
l'apocalypse avec un jus rencontrer des
gens je faisais du cocktail gervais les
gens je faisais l'ambiance je pouvais
chanter peut-être des petites chansons
je pouvais être dans une ambiance et une
gaieté qui pourrait laisser entrevoir
que quand même si vous m'arrêtez assis
un moment donné c'est trop lassés jeu
pouvait entrevoir que la vie était belle
dans un élément de christus combien un
cabaret à savoir l'apocalypse l'âge
appuyer les gens des fois je prend le
micro avec les niches daily deals et dj
comme tu dit wade fouad didi
je connais ma ni tandis est reconnu
alors ce midi l'ambiance j'aurais m'a
repéré lui peut-il à l'auteur de lima et
m'a dit tu veux faire du cinéma jeudi
mais tu te fous de ma gueule me dit non
pas du tout laisse tomber l'apocalypse
et en avant les dollars
segal cinéma c'est pas des birom la
sébile au vert 3g pas les déranger le
dollar a cédé euros ouais vous allez
coucher pour réussir
est-ce que j'ai coaché pour réussir oui
non j'ai accroché pour les non
franchement j'ai pas qu'aux si j'ai pas
dis jamais personne n'a décoché jamais
jamais arrêté vous l'avez fait
naturellement quoi way
par contre si je réussis alors là c'est
jeu pourrait cocher beaucoup ça vous
fait quoi je suis fou de vous voir dans
un film sur votre premier match tuzer
l'ardhis au web comme ça mais mais
attends c'est normal c'est la première
fois que tu viens à tout le monde en
parle
jc mairie je joue c'est votre premier
film qui vous fait quoi de vous
retrouver dans un film
bon franchement je te jure quand j'ai
fait la première fois au cinéma je
disais c'est quand même quelque chose
d'incroyable du repas soit le cinéma tu
vois pas tête qui bouge toi même à moi
même je me regarde
bon je sais pas comment quelqu'un qui
aime trop su voir un gym a pu dire j
matin les détails alors fait c'est la
dégringolade là j'en ai bien peur à
l'espace b c c'est quoi l'histoire le
film raconte votre vie d'une certaine
façon arrête de rigoler 1
celui ci tenait à 44,44 il est l'épée de
damoclès à la france non
je veux parler qui refusant j'aime pas
le même poids sur la table
je n'aime pas les gens qui se moquent
chez ceux qui pointent du doigt majoré
j'y suis et bien j'ai pas envie qu'on me
respecte ce sera tant les stands mais ça
va au fond n'est pas on n'est pas en
pièces
oui je suis ce film ça parle de quoi ça
raconte votre vie ça raconte ma vie
c'est un hommage à ma vie que je suis
venu du maghrib xj6 de m'intégrer que
j'ai rencontré l'amour j'ai assez même
un mode spécial air taille de manière
tout à fait libérale parce qu'on m'a
pointé du doigt j'y suis ici d'une
culture omc l'état est quand même un
tabou laisse tomber je vous le fais pas
dire
vas-y souilah regarde j'ai dit attention
je dis attention les gens surtout dans
une période en ce moment de crise où le
monde cynique le monde est ironique elle
fonde la peau l'errance mais il faut du
droit à la différence et me faut un
troisième moment en france la merci
beaucoup
cet été
et votre amant dans le film alain chabat
c'est un bon coup c'est beaucoup
ça va pas trop un bon écho à beaucoup
bon je peux pas dire c'est un bon coup
même si j'ai vécu des choses est sur la
place publique je peux pas me gâcher
toute façon ces films et maintenant ben
c'est filmé mais mais quand même elle
embrasse comme de manière à bois tamoul
et à quel jeu joue avec les moustaches
barbes aux pages cet été et est ce que
depuis le tournage du film vous n'êtes
pas un petit peu jalouse d'ophélie
winter
non parce que ben moi je le vois la
journée ouais mais je crois à la voile a
nourri ouais on attend que stan
équilibre au montant moi même je n'ai
pas très jalouse de la félibrée hunter
parce que j'ai eu moi-même je chante
oui moi même ceux capables d'envoûter
des mélopées à n'importe quelles
conséquences
je ne suis pas je ne sais pas je lui dis
pas non des autres je peux moi-même pour
une occasion de préciser ou même
aléatoire me laisser aller à la musique
à la rencontre soucieux
merci
alors
maintenant on show une question très
importante et comme c'est devenu une
star vous en pause et souvent on est
comme ça
si brad pitt vous proposer de faire un
film avec lui
est-ce que vous accepteriez brad est que
ces questionnaires brad pitt
brad pet déjà j'aime pas trop sur un
brad pitt
très franchement je vivrai oui moi je
sais pas parce que ça va être brad pitt
johnny depp on est que les sketchs que
je connais personnellement et aux autres
acteurs que vous connaissez pas moi ce
qui est important c'est le scénario
ouais c'est la séparation dans lequel on
va me mettre d'accord et contrairement à
beaucoup d'actrices françaises qui vont
commencer à vous prendre la tête avec le
personnage de sam way c'est aussi
l'implication personnelle que je vais
faire et j'aimerais mettre un autre
point sur la table car depuis quelques
temps je suis devenu intermédiaire du
spectacle ah bon
j'avais des problèmes maintenant un juge
vient j'aimerais mettre au grand jour et
sur la place publique des problèmes que
vivent les intermédiaires des spectacles
qui sont très importants en tant
qu'intermédiaire des spectacles je
trouve que c'est pas normal et loin de
moi un discours qui va dire pourquoi on
donne toujours aux maghrébins des rôles
de maghrébins non ma question c'est
pourquoi tout le temps dit rôle des
femmes
on y donne aux femmes arrivent et les
rangs des hommes en étant nous sommes
est ce que vous voulez l'ancien
intérieur de caméras vous regardez votre
caméra j'ai vu lancé un appel contre on
peut apprendre par exemple fm connus
comme les femmes oui par exemple vient
prendre mais pas menée sur 1 alors
qu'ils auraient pu prendre cette femme
et voilà en tant que leader claude
lelouch
qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle va faire un
homme et une femme à qui les budgets
nationaux
un homme troisième coffret qu'est-ce
qu'elle après un coffret 3 andré bien
bonjour l'imagination des plats france
de tomber à temps
je joue
dis moi oui si si il ya un seul film
vraiment qui a fait preuve de tolérance
dans le cinéma c'est beethoven car ils
ont pris un chien ah oui ce jeu vous
arrivez vous arrivez de mme agrebi
est-ce que c'est difficile d'être
homosexuel dans votre pays je joue très
bien entendu alors la laisse tomber les
gens vous juge vous regarde vous montre
du doigt un ça dépend du qu'elle sait
c'est pas demain cc c'est pas demain
qu'on aura une une gay pride à marrakech
quoi nita craque et en slip tort moi je
sais pas moi non je pense pas
franchement non je ne pense pas pour
l'instant il faut un épanouissement
encore beaucoup plus important qu'un non
pas pour l'instant tu joues en tant que
marocaine est ce que vous êtes prête à
partir en guerre contre les pointes
sèches et les cheveux cassants qui suis
honnête oui sol en cours une insolite
je pars je vais partir en guerre ben pas
celle que qui nous menacent la presse
que si je peux te dire que celle là
alors la laisse tomber
si dieu veut mais s'ils s'y prête à
partir en guerre pour des pointes sèches
qui suivent quatre sont toutes sortes de
combats la cellulite
alors là c'est pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
si vous aviez un mot à dire à tous les
travestis du monde ce soit je joue ça
serait quoi
j'aimerais dire là vont me donner
l'occasion de pouvoir m'exprimer je suis
désolé des parce que vous m'avez touché
qu'on voudrait ça que j'aimerais qu'ils
vivent leur personnalité leur identité
comme ils veulent et que tous les gens
au monde qui nous regardent maintenant
qu'ils se sont différents eh ben ça fait
plaisir qu'il veut comme il veut
je suis
disons les deux peut-être signer mission
de la rigolade peut-être non mais c'est
une émission de temps en temps on est
capable de dire des choses très
sérieuses déjeuner est le message que
vous faites passer ce soir c'est un
message de de la gym bien à votre mon
stage à l'espagne mais la gendarmerie
n'ont jamais fait de passer un message
de différence de tolérance de là il me
manque à mourens mais vive la france
vive la france
je joue qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur
aujourd'hui c'est d'être une femme ou de
ne pas être une femme
je crois vous touchez un point très
délicat très sensible vous remuez
quelque part et chier moi des choses
très fortes
je crois que les plus dire s'il ne pas
avoir est traîné comme une femme car
c'est un combat de tous les jours et par
un mois beaucoup de gens les tabous sont
là les gens vous jugent donc si de ne
pas être une femme qui est vraiment un
vrai combat
très émouvant je suis je crois que c'est
une réponse très émouvante
mais ça c'est un moment de télé hein y'a
que sur la télé qu'on peut avoir ça je
choque at il de plus féminin en vous du
féminin peut être bon pour parler
sérieusement et à ma sensibilité
ouais et peut-être des idées des partis
dits partie des dix deuxième partie de
soirée
chiche ou qu'at-il de plus masculin en
vous jure du plus masculin bon j'essaye
de le refouler
mais peut-être ce qui a déplu au
masculin c'est ma détermination ma
motivation
1 et quand je dis quelque chose je peux
te dire que ces commandes à vous
entendez me avec les hommes avec les
femmes avec des femmes
oui il n'y a pas de doute là dessus je
peux la comprendre qu'on si je peux lui
donner des avis personnel je peux te l'a
retourné la tête en 10 secondes
un homme un homme si facile l'homme est
très manipulable
non contrairement il plaît et les matchs
replay et dégonfler comme ça hein
les plus petits plus de 1 mais sauf
l'homme sensible attention donc sensible
intelligent l'homme qui l'a son cv des
pays qui sait devenir l'exacerber
exacerbée merci est ce que ça vous
montre que je suis fou de plus pouvoir
faire pipi debout
alors attention je contredis cette chose
car je ne vais pas y aller je veux pas
rentrer dans l'intimité
non je n'ai pas suivi encore avant mais
avec le cachet que j'ai perçu du cinéma
je ferai un voyage
dont les continents lointains si vous
étiez un homme chouchou quel genre de
femme vous attirerez madonna on a pour
moi c'est le comble de la sexualité à
outrance
ah ouais vous trouvez que c'est celle
qu'a l'air le plus [ __ ] quoi bon je
n'irai pas jusque là parce que j 10 amis
en algéro-marocaine regarde cette heure
ci ouais mais c'est une grosse ça alors
pas que j'aime bien je connais tous
d'accord non il n'y a pas de discussions
mais c'est agréable à regarder c'est une
grande artiste
je suis votre style d'homme c'est quoi
mon style d'homme c'est plutôt un combat
tu dirais daniel auteuil ah ouais style
tu manques qui comme un peu mystérieux
qui est pas trop exubérant même temps tu
sens très bien qui sait où et les vins
ce qu'il est seul en ce moment d'aller à
la bonne échelle en ce moment en pension
ugolin chichis
debout d'arrêter
vous demande de vous arrêter tu joues
comment pourrais-je vous séduire vous
oui moi dit je suis très romantique
moi aussi alors bon j'adore renifleurs
jouer bach à lille et eu du pain dit que
les mêmes aux as sauf les orchidées les
or qui dit c'est ma [ __ ] noir ça chez
nous où vous faites quelque chose après
l'émission
tu sais quoi
ouais rendez vous rendez vous après les
meilleurs hu
[Applaudissements]
ça
m
j'aimerais vous décorer
tu touches
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
je vais
[Musique]
voilà
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu